sur le numérique non mais vous êtes
parfaitement raison moi je vais vous
dire
en tant mis ça l'intérêt est un
ministère formidable les femmes les
hommes qui les composent qui composent
le ministère sont courageux travailleur
implantés mais faut avouer qu'on a un
problème c'est que nous ne savons pas
faire des projets numériques voilà c'est
un c'est un fait j'ai été pendant 3 ans
ministre des comptes publics j'ai le
bonheur de faire la poêle à source et la
dématérialisation de vos impôts je crois
que c'est une administration qui sait
faire ce genre de projet et quand je
suis arrivé à l'intérieur pour plein de
raisons que je pourrais vous expliciter
mais ça serait un peu long on ne sait
pas très bien les faire et ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent bon et ça c'est très
pas très efficient évidemment pour pour
le service public de la sécurité mais en
plus ça désespère Margaux qui
travaillent dans le commissariat parce
que la difficulté c'est que parfois on
oblige aujourd'hui des gens à réimprimer
des procédures numériques où il y a
tellement d'entrées dans la procédure
numérique c'est vraiment été fait par
des gens qui ont jamais vu de procédures
a priori voilà c'est pas été imaginé
comme ministère de la Justice enfin
franchement rien n'est rien n'était rien
n'est droit j'ai de changer une très
grande partie des choses on va changer
chef de projet on a mis beaucoup plus
d'argent on a mis à la tête de ces
projets des gens qui ont une certaine
conception de la vie informatique parce
que l'un des premiers pays nationales et
je dirais je voudrais dire un peu contre
si vous me permettez cette expression de
la gendarmerie c'est que comme il n'y
avait jusqu'à présent pas de formation
scientifique dans la police nationale
pour conduire des projets scientifiques
c'était plus dur le commissaire de
police il est fait pour plein de choses
mais peut-être pas pour diriger des
grands projets numériques parce que
c'est un autre métier voilà et donc
d'ailleurs je suis très heureux de voir
que l'École polytechnique désormais
accepte les quatre commissaires de
police qui sortent de cette école pour
pouvoir justement dans la police
nationale avoir des formations
scientifiques comme on les ont les
gendarmes qui qui ont réussi à faire à
la fois des sens si rien des
polytechniciens des gens qui venaient
d'ailleurs et donc oui on a des
problèmes numériques très importants et
c'est très fort en fait elle va elle va
elle va les aider à aller mieux me
semble-t-il d'abord parce que en même
temps vous avez voté la locmi avec des
moyens supplémentaires mais aussi un
certain nombre de changements profonds
la en ligne et la visio plainte c'est
une transformation dès le début parce
que qu'est-ce qu'on a fait dans le
procédure numérique jusqu'à présent en
fait c'était le monde papier qu'on
transformait en numérique et comme la
justice allait pas forcément suivie la
taille des tuyaux on réimprimé pour la
justice voilà alors que là le début
c'est dès le début on fait du numérique
à commencer par le dépôt de plainte et
je pense que ça changera énormément de
choses y compris dans les saisines fait
par les par les magistrats donc si
j'entends vos interrogations et celle
des agents en fait je crois qu'on repart
un peu from scratch sur deux grands
projets Scribe et rppn on aura aussi
l'occasion d'en reparler mais en fait ça
ne marche pas indépendamment de la
réforme de la police nationale et et
nous faisons les deux en même temps et
ça sera une très bonne chose